e
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le
[Musique]
tous
le caniche on pourrait même dire les
caniches car il forme une vraie famille
est tous différents et uniques avec leur
sac couleur de robe et leurs cadres
taille sans compter qu'il existe une
variété à poil cordes et le caniche
royal et de nombreux types de toilettage
il circule un certain nombre d'idées
reçues qui veulent faire du caniche un
chien de salon ou tout au moins
d'appartements en réalité ses origines
sont extrêmement rustique il veut
longtemps utilisées pour la chasse au
canard dans laquelle il excellait grâce
à ses aptitudes exceptionnelles de
majeur la tombe du postérieur avait un
rôle purement fonctionnel car elle lui
permettait de mieux se mouvoir dans
l'eau est allégé d'en sortir plus
aisément sous des airs de petit chien
fragile autres laitages parfois
extravagants le caniche et débordant de
vitalité d'espièglerie une vraie
thérapie contre la tristesse son
aptitude au jeu et son extraordinaire
mémoire font que le caniche reviendra
rapidement ce que vous lui enseignez à
brax sophistiqué doux comme un agneau
intelligent comme un sage
le caniche séduit que vous soyez
casanier ou sportives jeunes vieux
valade concours de beauté ou de naturel
vous pourrez trouver le bonheur avec ce
merveilleux compagnon
[Musique]
le caniche est classé numéro 1 des
demandes des particuliers en france plus
de 4000 naissances ont été enregistrées
en 1993
l'évolution est constante et plutôt
rapide le gnl devrait dépasser 40 2000
sujet je pense qu'il est préférable que
les particuliers viennent acheter les
chiens dans l'est dans des élevages pour
qu'ils puissent voir les parents et pour
qu'on puisse leur donner un suivi
d'élevage sérieux pour leur petit chien
en principe je demande aux gens de
prendre les chiots vers trois mois c'est
le moment idéal pour avoir un petit
chiot on a un chiot qui est vraiment
bien ce break et bien séparé de sa mère
qui a eu deux vaccins et qui peut partir
dans des conditions optimales pour les
futurs acquéreurs
à l'âge adulte le chien devra être
confirmée par un expert pour que la
société centrale canine puisse établir
son pedigree
[Musique]
même le gars mailhiot le caniche
s'adapte à toutes les situations
sage et calme avec des personnes d'un
certain âge il devient vif et nerveux en
compagnie d'une personne active avec
toujours beaucoup d'humour et de
tendresse
c'est un chien dos il est doté d'une
remarquable intelligence avec un esprit
d'initiative toujours en éveil
comme il est intelligent il a équilibré
charme et sincérité sensible jusqu'à
l'émotivité
il supporte mal l'éloignement de son
maître il est attachant est attaché
le cliché est un chien aguets
intelligent il est il est joueur avec
les enfants il est il est agréable à
vivre à c'est un chien qui est vraiment
très attrayant point de vue de son
caractère et il est très enjoué il est
toujours gai toujours prêt à bondir à
courir à jouer avec avec les enfants les
grand caniche ont généralement le
tempérament des grands chiffres
particulièrement équilibré et posé quant
aux autres plus ils sont petits plus ils
sont vifs voire un peu collant on dit
parfois que les sujets de couleur grise
ou abricots sont plus nerveux que leur
demi-frère
en fait la ligne et compte davantage que
la couleur ou la taille dans
l'établissement du cratère
[Musique]
le caniche est classé dans la catégorie
déchets un utilitaire les deux
compagnies on distingue quatre tailles
legrand 45 à 55 cm maximum au garrot le
moyen 35 à 45 cm le nain moins de 35 cm
et le toy de 20 à 30 cm quelle que soit
la taille le caniche garde les mêmes
caractéristiques
sa démarche est légère et souriante le
port élégant et fier le regard vif est
il ne doit jamais avoir une allure
coulante ou allongée la tête et
distinguée et proportionnée au corps
marqué une légère préférence à l'arrière
le dessin 10 km doit apparaître sous la
peau avec netteté le stop est très peu
marqué le crâne doit être bien modelés
sa largeur inférieure à la moitié de la
longueur de la tête
le chanfrein est solide la truffe est
développé avec des narines ouverte
les yeux sont en forme d'amande de
couleur noire on prend très foncé pour
les caniche noir blanc gris et abricots
ils peuvent être en bray foncez chez les
caniches marron
les oreilles assez longue platon bancs
le long des joues s'arrondissent à
l'extrémité ailes sont recouvertes de
poils longs et ondulés l'encolure est
solide légèrement argué après la mue est
bien proportionné à noter l'absence de
fanon le dos et cours et d'une ligne
harmonieuse et reims ont fermé muscler
la croupe arrondis mais pas tombante
plutôt petit les pieds sont formées d'un
ovale cours l'épaule est oubliée muscler
le ventre et les flancs sont remontés
sans être l'oeuvre était la poitrine est
descendu à hauteur du coude
sa largeur est égal au tiers de sa
hauteur les membres antérieurs son droit
et parallèles élégant et bien musclé les
membres postérieurs son parallèle avec
des muscles développer apparent les
cuissons muscles et robuste le
raccordement avec le jarret à ses coudes
et le caniche doit naître sans ergo aux
membres postérieurs
la queue est attaché à ces eaux à la
hauteur de la ligne rhin elle se relève
obliquement quand le chien est en action
[Musique]
le poilu caniche doit être abondant
d'une texture fine laineuse et bien
frisé l'uniformité de longueur et son
épaisseur sont de rigueur mes boucles
doivent être égales et peigné
[Musique]
chez le poil cordes et les qualités sont
les mêmes avec un poil plus serré que le
poil soit bouclé aux cordes et il existe
5 couleur de robe noir blanc gris marron
et abricots teinte qui se doivent d'être
franche et uniforme
toutefois quelques poils blancs sont
tolérés au poitrail
tel est le standard très officielle du
caniche qui bien entendu le prof cupra
pas tout le monde mais témoignant moins
d'une certaine recherche de qualité du
chien et du respect de ses origines
[Musique]
savoir que le chiot on est en quelque
sorte non finis c'est à dire qu'il n'a
est sourd et aveugle et que par exemple
il n'entend que vers le quatorzième jour
le conduit auditif même est obturé alors
il n'est pas non plus capable de se
déplacer à la naissance il fait partie
de ce qu'on appelle les espèces ni dix
cols il ne peut pas se déplacer comme un
tout la le peut par exemple à la
naissance du chiot ne le peut pas il
n'est même pas capable de rampes et
convenablement parce qu'il ya un
phénomène qu'on appelle la myéline
isation ce une gaine de myéline qui
entoure les fibres nerveuses et qui
permet la conduction de l'influx nerveux
depuis la zone cervicales jusqu'à
l'extrémité des membres inférieurs des
membres postérieurs
or chez le chiot 7 me aline isation
n'est pas terminée à la naissance est de
loin on dit souvent que tout se joue
dans les six premiers mois mais c'est
vrai mais même ça se joue dans les six
premières semaines
c'est très court et l'apprentissage
entre autres de la hiérarchie de la
communication l'apprentissage de
l'environnement même tout simplement se
fait dans les six premières semaines de
vie
[Musique]
durant les quinze premiers jours de leur
vie période dite néonatale les shows
dans plus de 90% du temps il se réveille
pour étaient sept à huit fois par jour
pour favoriser l'écoulement du lait le
chiot pousse sur la mamelle avec le
museau et les pattes avant les
mouvements de succion d'un chai au
réveil les autres et les entraîne à
boire tous ensemble les besoins naturels
se font de manière purement réflexe la
mer les déclenche en léchant le ventre
du jeune elle absorbe ainsi toutes les
éliminations et le nid reste propre
le chiot dès la naissance possède la
sensibilité thermique et gustative
capable de discerner le chaud du froid
qui permet entre autres de rechercher le
contact de la mer et de discerner oui si
le goût du lait maternel de toutes
autres substances
c2c 200 cela la sensibilité thermique et
la sensibilité gustatives existe dès la
naissance
les progrès les plus significatifs
s'observe au niveau du comportement
locomoteur très vite l'animal se
déplacent plus facilement le jour de
l'ouverture des paupières marque la fin
de la période néonatale
pendant la troisième semaine le sens
olfactif le fameux nez du chien se
développe considérablement les activités
se diversifient car les périodes d'éveil
salon jeunes elle représente bientôt 40
% du temps le reste du temps est occupée
par du sommeil calme et du sommeil dit
activée parce que agitée de légères
convulsions
[Musique]
à cet âge on ne peut pas encore parler
de communication auditive ou visuelle
car les comportements sociaux évoluent
de pair avec les organes des sens et la
vue comme louis ne sont pas encore
effectives
par contre il existe une communication
tactile le léchage mutuel et la
recherche du contact corporel
dès la fin de la troisième semaine
le chou sursaute au moindre bruit ils
commencent à entendre ce fait important
marque la fin de la période dite de
transition
[Musique]
le chiot va devoir découvrir son
environnement et le comportement
locomoteur qui forcément lié au
comportement d'investigation il faut que
l'animal puisse se déplacer pour
l'explorer son environnement lui ne
commencent à prendre effet que lorsque
le chien on peut se déplacer autrement
qu'en rampant plus ou moins efficacement
plus ou moins maladroitement et ça on le
voit débuté que vers la troisième
semaine pendant la quatrième semaine le
chiot affine son louis et sa vue tandis
que sont la perte ward call s'élargit
considérablement son rythme veille
sommeil se rapproche de celui d'adulte
il est actif plus de 65 % du temps sa
démarche est encore maladroite mais ils
n'hésitent pas à se lancer dans le
franchissement d'obstacles démesurés dès
la 5e semaine tous les shows sorte de
systématiquement du nid pour éliminer à
6 cette semaine le choix qu'il est
différent réflexe qui font que la
coordination motrice est quasi
comparable à celle de l'adulte
[Musique]
pendant la période de socialisation le
chiot pour en contact avec le monde
extérieur
c'est le moment privilégié pour la
construction des relations sociales au
sein de sa famille
il apprend les moyens de communications
mais il doit aussi faire connaissance
avec les autres espèces et il est bon
que ces rencontres se fasse durant cette
période d'apprentissage de
l'environnement
on observe qu entre trois et cinq
semaines le chiot est attiré par tous
les êtres vivants quelle qu'en soit
l'espèce et les identifie en retenant
leurs caractéristiques
à partir de cinq semaines l'attraction
pour l'inconnu diminué se transforme
même en craintes ont peur voire en
aversion après la septième semaine
on peut en déduire de la période la plus
favorable pour l'apprentissage des
espèces se situe entre la troisième et
la sixième semaine
la période qui suit jusqu'à la fin de la
7e semaine en représente sans doute le
meilleur moment pour adapter le chiot un
nouveau milieu puisque l'essentiel de
l'apprentissage avec la fratrie est
terminée et que l'attraction sociale est
encore agissante communication de
quelque chose d'extrêmement important
pour que des individus du même d'une
même espèce puisse avoir des relations
de groupe entre elle et tous les chiots
de n'importe quelle race apprennent les
mêmes signes de communication
c'est-à-dire des principalement des
postures des attitudes mais aussi des
vocalises la sicap est le jeu qui est
caractérisée par le fait que l'animal
frappe le sol avec les antérieurs l'est
le postérieur agit-là que si on lui en a
laissé une sas et la même attitude
quelle que soit la race du chien quelle
que soit sa provenance quel que soit son
pays d'origine c'est un pas important ce
alors il y a aussi un apprentissage est
essentielle au sein de la fratrie au
sein du groupe
c'est l'apprentissage de la hiérarchie
les chiots apprennent toutes les
postures exprimant à la fois la
domination et la soumission dans les
différentes expressions il y à aussi
l'expression de la peur la peur on va
souvent avec toute une mimiques faciales
elle est exprimée par toute une mimiques
faciales les oreilles qui se replient
vers l'arrière les commissures des
lèvres les yeux qui s'étire vers
l'arrière
le regard fuyant et puis très souvent le
chien qui s'abaisse qui s'aplatit
s'aplatit au sol si la peur est suivie
d'un comportement de soumission qui
n'est pas forcément lié avec la peur la
peur peut déclencher un comportement
d'agression bien sûr mais si
l'aboutissement de la peur et la
soumission on observe une autre posture
très caractéristique
mais qui peut avoir plusieurs formes ce
que les gens voient de plus
spectaculaire c'est le chien se mettre
sur le dos exposer les parties génitales
exposées l'abdomen et bien sûr que c'est
une soumission poussé à son expression
la plus claire
mais le simple fait de s'aplatir au sol
surtout de baisser la tête et de
détourner le regard
c'est une expression de soumission
parfaitement clair non le scion a donc
le monde à découvrir cette exploration
fait appel à tous les organes des sens
tout et investigués avec les yeux les
oreilles le nez et la bouche de la
période de socialisation dépendra le
caractère du chien
si durant ce laps de temps il est mis en
contact avec des personnes et des
situations diverses
s'ils rencontrent des espèces
différentes il grandira bien dans sa
peau sans peur et capable de s'adapter à
n'importe quel milieu
yalla yalla
le caniche s'adapte avec toutes les
races de chiens si le chien est plus
gros que lui il va se laisser dominer
par contre si c'est un grand caniche
avec un plus petit chien il va peut-être
le dominer mais en principe c'est un
chien qui est doux avec les avec les
autres chiens n'y a pas de problème
particulier
par contre avec les animaux comme c'est
quand même un chien qui a été à
l'origine d'un très bon chasseur il faut
faire attention avec les volailles
évidemment et les animaux genre cochons
d'inde ou lapins nains qui peuvent
prendre évidemment pour un gibier et
tout ça à partir du caniche nain qui
peut très bien avoir des instincts
chasseurs
[Musique]
peu de chiens ont donné lieu à autant de
controverses quant à leur origine la
plus flatteuse de ces suppositions est
sans conteste celle avancée par le grand
naturaliste monsieur le buffon qui
n'hésitait pas à considérer cette race
comme l'ancêtre de tous les chiens
domestiques m
mais cette hypothèse ne repose sur rien
de suffisamment concrets pour que l'on
puisse aujourd'hui l'accréditer certains
textes par contre confirmerait que le
caniche aurait d'accompagner les
musulmans au viiie siècle lorsque
ceux-ci commencèrent leur expansion vers
l'afrique du nord
l'espagne puis la france ce chien était
en fête le barbe est chargé de veiller
sur leurs précieuses rupo selon toute
vraisemblance c'est donc de la rencontre
du barbet arabes et des chiens d'eau
portugais ou espagnols les fameux chaos
des agua et perrot des agua que naquit
ce qui allait devenir au fil des siècles
une race à part entière le caniche le
nom de caniches proviendrait du nom
caniche on petit canard qui lui aurait
été attribué au regard de ses qualités
particulières dans la chasse aux canards
les choses deviennent plus claires en ce
qui concerne le caniche vers la fin du
moyen âge époque à laquelle on rencontre
les premiers caniche plus ou moins
toiletter ou entièrement rasés c'est au
xviie siècle que le caniche qui peu à
peu les marais pour entrer dans les
salons les éleveurs s'attache à produire
des sujets plus petit et donc plus
enclins à fréquenter les boudoirs c'est
ainsi que le caniche nain fait son
entrée à la cour du roi louis saez et
que sa popularité bacon dix ans jusqu'au
second empire en 1925 mano adjoint cours
est à l'origine de la création du club
du caniche
c'est seulement en 1936 que la
fédération cynologique internationale
reconnaissant standard
[Musique]
docile et d'une remarquable intelligence
il ne posera aucun problème pour son
éducation
la propreté d'abord amener l'eau
rapidement là où vous désirez qu'ils
fassent désormais ses besoins
bien sûr il est peu évident qu'ils se
plient tout de suite à votre volonté
lorsque ce sera le cas félicité le
chaudement afin de lui faire comprendre
qu'il vous a fait un immense plaisir
qu'un chien provoqué la joie de son
maître et caresser les compliments sont
réellement les bases de toute éducation
canine
ça doit toujours se passer en douceur
ça ne doit jamais être assorties de
sanctions
c'est complètement inutile là aussi on
voit nombre d'erreurs se commettre
toujours en fonction de lave la fameuse
fut anthropomorphique c'est à dire
essayer de trouver une explication
comportement du sud en se servant de
comportements humains
et puis être persuadé que le show c'est
qu'il a mal fait quelque chose ou qu'il
a eu tort de faire quelque chose au
moment où il y la paix n'en sais rien ce
pour un animal vient d'une espèce et
d'une espèce qui n'est pas la nôtre
on lui apprend à vivre dans un
appartement évident que si d'urines sur
un tapis
sané port la manière stupide est encore
trop fréquentes enfoncé le nez dans une
flaque d'uriné qui va lui apprendre que
dix minutes avant il a eu tort d'uriné
la comprendra rien au comportement de
l'être humain à ce moment là mais comme
c'est un chiot et comme il est bien
socialiser comme il a bien appris
comment répondre à une agression il va
adopter une attitude de soumission et
c'est là qu'il n'y a souvent dit peu de
divergences entre la réalité et ce
qu'imaginent les propriétaires mucyo
voyant le chiot se soumettre lorsqu'ils
traitent de cette façon qui n'est pas
très agréable
ils ont conclu que le chiot c'est qu'il
a mal fait
ah non il ne sait pas qu'il a mal fait
il sait qu'il est agressée comme il est
agressé il répond aux chiens bien
socialiser lire il adopte une attitude
de soumission qui n'est pas une attitude
de culpabilité le grand caniche est très
très facile à éduquer moi-même quand
j'ai acheté mon premier chien c'était un
grand caniche et comme je savais pas
j'avais jamais eu de chien donc je ne
savais pas comment
duke est un chien je suis allé dans des
réunions de propriétaires qui veulent
éduquer leur chien est en fait ma
chienne apprenait en très peu de temps
la même chose qu'un berger allemand ou
aucun shsh n'osèrent elles apprenaient à
s'asseoir à se coucher et même à
distance elle avait de bons résultats et
il faut tout de même se souvenir que le
chien appartient à une espèce différente
et que les mots n'ont pas de sens pour
lui
à preuve c'est que nous avons dû
apprendre un autre jeune chiot son nom
mais ce qui est bien plus important que
les mots c'est l'intonation et plus
encore que l'intonation ce sont les
gestes joindre le geste à la parole pour
essayer de faire comprendre quelque
chose à son chien c'est véritablement la
meilleure méthode
il ya quand même un truc dans leur appel
qui est très important c'est la position
accroupie un chien ce revient toujours
plus facilement sur une personne qui est
accroupi que sur une personne qui
restent debout planté qui est plus
agressif vis-à-vis du chien qu'une
personnes accroupies qui est beaucoup
plus sympathique et qui se met à sa
hauteur et qui fait que le chien revient
éventuellement lui sauter dessus lui
n'était pas de tout l'éducation au
départ c'est surtout beaucoup de
patience il faut quand même de la
fermeté et de la récompense évidemment
la récompense la récolte la meilleure
récompense et la caresse si vous avez
une friandise
ou de ces c'est bien aussi mais faut pas
abuser de la friandise patio la caresser
bien suffisant pour le grand caniche
il faut être assez ferme tout en étant
gentil c'est un chien qui est très
facile à éduquer avec un petit peu de
patience
n'importe qui peut y arriver
[Musique]
[Rires]
le chien polyvalent par excellence petit
chien d'appartement depuis des
générations
cela n'empêche pas d'aller piquer une
tête dans un étang dans ses gènes
il n'a pas oublié qu'ils étaient ses
ancêtres le grand caniche en particulier
est un excellent chien marais
[Musique]
à
au départ c'était un très très bon
retriever cas et est maintenant
abandonné pour le labrador et je pense
beaucoup pour des raisons de toilettage
parce qu'en fait si on veut avoir un
beau caniche et chasser avec lui c'est
un travail épouvantable tous les
dimanches soirs où les lundis matin en
rentrant de l'achat si il y aurait un
travail de longue haleine pour lui
enlever toutes les herbes qui l'a de
coller dans sa fourrure sport canin en
plein développement l'agility est l'une
des plus récentes forme de compétitions
canines donc s'évalue la forme physique
du chien et l'attitude de l'homme à
l'éduquer comparable au saut d'obstacles
en équitation le parcours d'agility
associe le son de l escalade et la
descente de palissades oblique la poutre
le slalom la bascule d'une aile et la
table accessible à toutes les races
l'agilité peut être pratiqué par les
chiens avec ou sans pedigree le caniche
de par son intelligence et son agilité
excellent dans cette discipline parfaite
illustration de la complicité du couple
homme chien
l'agility associés activités sportives
éducation et détente tout en développant
les aptitudes naturelles du chien
reconnu par tous l'agility connaît une
forte expansion
chaque année sont organisées les
compétitions régionales nationales et
internationales qui contribuent à sa
popularité auprès de tous les amis des
chiens quand on voit évoluer ses chiens
et leurs maîtres
c'est extrêmement sympathique il ya une
relation qui s'améliorent entre le
propos est propriétaire du chien et le
chien puisque c'est le propriétaire du
chien qui normalement conduit le chien
dans un lieu attractif dans un lieu de
jeu et ça ne peut qu'améliorer la
relation
[Musique]
il faut savoir que le caniche qui le
perd pas ses poils doit être tout l'été
pour se présenter une exposition et que
le règlement des épreuves de bouter ne
tolère que quatre types de toilettage
moderne en lion al anglaise époux pis si
l'on est tenté par l'idée de présenter
son caniche lors d'une exposition canine
il faut s'y préparer avec soin à prendre
certaines règles indispensables au bon
déroulement des opérations et habitués
le chien à bien se comporter lorsqu'il
sera jugé la peur et la nervosité étant
considérés comme des défauts le chien
devra être habitué à être manipulé le
juge se devant de l'examiner sous toutes
les coutures
il devrait également savoir évoluer
correctement aux trois allures pas trot
galop et marcher en laisse sentir et
sagement aux côtés de son maître
un prix acquis au cours d'une exposition
de beauté régional ou international n'a
pour le mettre qu'une valeur honorifique
mais bon le chien il atteste de sa
conformité aux standards et pour le
promouvoir en vue d'une reproduction
destiné à préserver le patrimoine
génétique et bordeaux logique de la race
[Musique]
m
avant contre les télés khenniche en
couple lyon c'est à dire qu'on les sait
effectivement toute la toison comme
cette coupe là mais ici on condé très
très court avec la tondeuse en laissant
des petits pompons en bas en dessous
jarre est devant on comptait également
au niveau des bras et ont laissé les
concombres arendt ou les pâtes
maintenant le toilettage un caniche a
beaucoup évolué et nous en sommes
arrivés à la coupe du pi entre autres la
pupille scandinave dont qui vient de
scandinavie
mais on peut également présenter des
chiens en coupe moderne c'est à dire
qu'on allait tout à foison et on fait
tout aux ciseaux tous au même niveau et
là effectivement on trouve le poids de
la tête pour faire ce qu'on appelle une
groupe
c'est un grand caniche grand caniche
blanc qu elle est coupée en coupe
d'exposition ce qu'on appelle la coupe
pillant donc c'est à dire course sur les
fesses mais aussi zoo n'ont pas la
tondeuse et tout le reste on regarde le
poil au niveau des toisons point d'avoir
le plus possible donc celle-ci bon on
n'a pas encore beaucoup parce que là est
encore autre jeune voilà est donc là on
va d'abord commencer par la coiffer et
ensuite commencé à la couper
donc là on va couper les fesses il faut
que ce niveau ce soit bien court on
remonte en général jusqu'à la dernière
côte
[Musique]
et on fait ce qu'on appelle du velours
donc c'est à dire on met tous les poids
le même niveau
[Musique]
cette partie n'a cependant fait partie
la donne vraiment avec tricot de façon à
faire ressortir l'angulation du chien
donc ici se doit être fait très court et
là on laisse un maximum de poils et bien
sûr en détourant les pattes
ensuite une fois qu'on a bien raccourci
à l'arrière puisque caniche doit être
court et doit être dans un carré eh bien
on raccourcit le devant tout le devant
du chien et on marque les pattes
[Musique]
une fois qu'on a faits sont devant
on va marquer donc le début de cet
oiseau look elle comme elle est jeune
elle est évidemment pas encore à cette
poêle mais on commence à marquer le
dessous
on est toujours à l'eva tâte
alors si le chien a un bon pied ont des
tours bien ont bien remonté la patrie
mais par contre si chez anna paquebot
pieds là on ne détour pas trop
[Musique]
voilà
alors sur la queue sur les chaînes
expositions ont tous la tâche de là que
c'est à dire le début de la queue pour
que justement encore la chaîne portera
sa queue qu'elle soit démarqué du corps
donc on tond et ensuite on vous dit que
il suffit de faire un concours
[Musique]
alors bien sûr sur la tête on ne coupe
pas
on essaye de garder le plus de poils
possible afin de pouvoir faire un top
nude en exposition et donc pour pas que
les poils répandent dans les yeux on va
tout simplement mettre un petit
élastique
[Musique]
là
alors bien sûr on ne coupe pas le poil
des oreilles et on essaye de garder
justement le plus de points possibles
afin d'obtenir une très jolie tête
[Musique]
donc là sur un chien un petit peu plus
âgé on voit bien la coupe c'est à dire
cours ici là bien serré et tout le poil
qui part derrière pour bien voir
l'angulation ici biencourt là on garde
bien toute la toise on ne touche pas les
pattes avant son cas était normalement
ici on n'a pas touché non plus au top
notes ni aux oreilles
le toilettage reste même aussi bien sûr
un grand sur un moyen ou sur un ton est
donc là on a vu les coupes d'exposition
maintenant entre les tâches commerciales
il existe différentes coupes qui diffère
d'un salon ou un autre qui peut être
aussi bien tout aux ciseaux tout le
corps et les pâques aux tisons ou bien
on peut le dos relais du poil sur les
pattes avec ou sans démarcation
chaque salon à son appellation et son
style de coupe
[Musique]
oh
lorsque vous achetez un chien celui ci
doit obligatoirement être tatoués ou
identifié peut-être un jour à led micro
puce électronique que l'on plaque sous
la boue entre la 8e et la 9e semaine on
va mettre en oeuvre le véritable
programme de vaccination du show et
commencer par une primo vaccination
contre la maladie de carré l'hépatite de
rue barca leptospirose la parvovirose
bien sûr et puis enfin bien évidemment
la rage
vous avez fait l'acquisition d'un petit
chiot caniche est la première des choses
à faire c'est de vous rendre chez votre
vétérinaire
elles sont à constater que tout ce passe
bien assez chaude alain dony les
français est nécessaire et surtout qui
procède au rappel de vaccination et bat
en oeuvre un plan de vérification qui
permettra de traiter les parasites
intestinaux dont ce chien va forcément
souffrir car de fait la mère lui a
transmis ses par exemple selon son
format l'âge adulte la croissance va
durer chez le chiot caniche d'une
dizaine à une quinzaine de mois c'est
durant cette période qu'on va bien sûr
les ducs et en évitant et cela est
impératif de lui faire pratiquer toutes
formes d'exercice trop brusque en effet
c'est durant cette période que se
forment le squelette de l'animal et il
serait par trop sévère pour lui en
particulier pour tout ce que l'aide de
lui demander des efforts violents tels
que des descentes d'escaliers trop
intempestive ou de le faire courir trop
longtemps chaque jour
régulièrement elle est un coton imbibé
de sérum physiologique et il faut
nettoyer le coin des paupières pour y
retirer les sécrétions part pour bien
nettoyer les oreilles d'un caniche il
est très utile parfois de l'épi
développement à la main ce qui permet
d'éviter que s'accumulent à la série un
certain nombre de bactéries
enfin les dents de notre caniche mérite
d'être particulièrement entretenu dans
la mesure où 8h30 circuler facilement ce
qui a pour effet bien de générer soit
des problèmes infectieux de tic
gingivite mais surtout de lui donner
parfois mauvaise haleine une petite
remarque vétérinaire concernant le
caniche et plus particulièrement le cac
michelin c'est l'existence dans cette
race de manière rares et comme dans
d'autres races de deux affections qui
peuvent avoir une origine génétique
c'est tout d'abord la trophy progressive
de la rétine contre laquelle il existe
des tests et ces tests sont
obligatoirement mis en oeuvre dans le
cadre duquel du caniche pas l'inquiétude
l'anc et puis c'est une maladie
cardiaque qui est la persistance du
canal artériel maladie que l'on peut
dépister très précocément et qui se
soigne par voie chirurgicale trois
affections auquel il convient de faire
attention et qu'il convient également de
prévenir dans la mesure du possible chez
le caniche lorsqu'il est adulte c'est
chez le caniche nain les luxation de la
rotule qui se manifeste par boiterie
intermittente et qui sont justifiables
d'une intervention chirurgicale
chez le caniche de format standard c'est
l'émergence de problèmes oculaires avec
l'apparition de cataracte et enfin pour
l'ensemble des caniches dans la mesure
où on ne prend pas garde à les alimenter
convenablement
c'est le risque d'obésité faut savoir
qu'actuellement plus d'un tiers des
caniches se révéler trop belle ce qui a
pour conséquence est bien de prédisposer
ses chiens à tout un tas de maladies qui
deux problèmes de peau les problèmes de
diabète en passant par du surmenage
cardiaque
toutes choses qui bien évidemment vont
réduire leur espérance de vie et qui
sont simples à prévenir tout simplement
en s'intéressant de près leur
alimentation
[Musique]
cette alimentation elle commence dès la
gestation est à dire en l'occurrence de
quarante cinquième jeu de cette
gestation période à laquelle on va
augmenter les apports alimentaires
d'environ 25 pour caen et se tourner
vers des aliments un petit peu enrichi
en protéines ensuite la sienne d'entrer
dans la phase de lactation elle va donc
produire du lait pour allaiter ses
shoots requis est une demande mais
fessionnels très importante pour elle et
pour couvrir ses besoins nutritionnels
supplémentaires il va falloir se tourner
vers des aliments hyper concentré tantôt
plan énergétique coplan protéique
l'idéal étant d'avoir recours à des
aliments secs enrichi en matières
grasses et en protéines la période de
sevrage qui va débuter à la quatrième
semaine va nécessiter de faire appel à
ce que l'on appelle une bouillie sevrage
oui sevrage qui distribué pendant une
période d'une quinzaine de jours va
permette d'assurer une transition très
progressive pour le show du lait
maternel aliments liquides hyper
concentrés vers un aliment spécialisés
pour sa croissance
aliment complet sec ou ration ménagère
pet par le propriétaire
le nombre de repas par jour durant la
croissance sera après le sevrage au
début de cette croissance de trois repas
matin midi soir à leurs pics en quantité
équivalente toujours dans la même
gamelle on pourra dès l'âge de quatre à
cinq mois passés à deux repas quotidien
le matin et le soir pour enfin terminer
cette croissance et maintenir à l'âge
adulte la cadence d'un repas quotidien
chaque soir si ce caniche à une vie
d'appartements relativement lascives et
bien on se tournera vers un aliments
allégés hypocalorique si le chien est
actif paix de l'agility du sport promène
beaucoup il y en aura tendance à excuser
a nettement plus concentrée au plan
énergétique
[Musique]
le caniche est un chien tout enjoué
intelligent farceur si la race propose
des variétés pour tous les goûts le
grand caniche a besoin d' espaces et si
lui dans l'appartement
l'exercice lui est indispensable les
petites tailles
le na et le toy s'adapteront mieux au
milieu urbain mais quelle que soit sa
taille ou la couleur de sa robe
son caractère doux et affectueux en fera
le compagnon idéal
sont l'éducation développera sa mémoire
et son affection à l'égard de son maître
avec lui il est prêt à toutes les
aventures
[Musique]
toute la journée
on
m
[Musique]
mon temps
on
tél
[Musique]
m